Más de 250 millones de personas viven en
un país distinto al que nacieron... es decir,
que son inmigrantes.
Y, ojo, amigos, porque este número no para
de crecer.
En los últimos 50 años se ha multiplicado
por 3 y tan solo desde el año 2000, el número
de inmigrantes se ha incrementado, atentos,
en ¡80 millones!, 80 millones de personas
que se han marchado de su país en busca de
una vida mejor.
Y tal y como os podéis imaginar la mayoría
de todos los inmigrantes que hay en el mundo
- más del 65% - se han establecido en los
países más ricos, en países como
Estados Unidos, Alemania, Australia o Canadá.
Y esto es, precisamente, queridos amigos de
VisualPolitik, el motivo que está alimentando,
a lo largo y ancho del mundo... controvertidos,
furiosos y encarnizados debates sobre la inmigración….
y también, el discurso de muchos movimientos
populistas.
En los últimos años, sin ir más lejos,
en Europa, por ejemplo, estamos viendo cómo
están surgiendo un montonazo de partidos
populistas y xenófobos... que han puesto
a la inmigración directamente en la diana.
[Qué si nos roban el trabajo, que si nos
ponen en peligro, que si destruyen nuestras
identidad nacional, etcétera, etcétera.]
Pero... tal vez, con todo, el caso con diferencia
más importante es el de Donald Trump.
Un presidente que ha dejado claro, muy claro,
que la inmigración no le gusta absolutamente
nada….
salvo, al parecer, alguna que otra excepción.
Fijaos:
(Según medios locales como el Washington
Post y el New York Times, Trump dijo que EE.UU.
no debería recibir inmigrantes de "países
de mierda" como El Salvador o las naciones
africanas sino de Noruega." BBC)
[Por qué diantres pensará Trump que los
noruegos quieren emigrar masivamente a
Estados Unidos, cuando ya son más ricos que los norteamericanos.]
Pero… no nos desviemos.
Amigos,
¿Es realmente la inmigración un peligro,
una carga, un lastre?
¿Están los Estados Unidos perdiendo empuje
económico por culpa de todos los inmigrantes
que hay en el país?
¿Tienen, acaso, los EEUU que frenar la llegada
de más extranjeros?
Veámoslo.
Si en algo vamos a estar todos de acuerdo,
es en que vivimos en un mundo que cada vez
está más interconectado, es decir, donde
cada vez resulta más fácil, más rápido
y más barato ir de un sitio a otro.
Y donde, también, cada vez es más fácil
contactar con nuestros seres queridos sin
importar el lugar donde nos encontremos..
Y… como os podéis imaginar todos estas
son cosas que hacen que tomar la decisión
de hacer las maletas y marcharse a otro país
sea mucho, pero que mucho más fácil.
Por eso… si en los años 60 había 90 millones
de inmigrantes en todo el mundo, hoy ya son
más de 250 millones…
Y ¿sabéis qué?
Podemos esperar que este número crezca con
fuerza en los próximos años.
Primero, porque cada vez es más fácil moverse,
y segundo por el enorme crecimiento demográfico
que están experimentando muchos países pobres.
Así que, amigos, la pregunta es, ¿hay motivos
para preocuparse?
Atentos.
(¿UN GOLPE DE SUERTE?)
Cada vez que en los países ricos se habla
sobre inmigración parece que se está debatiendo
sobre si hacer o no una especie de obra de
caridad.
Y… ¿sabéis qué?
Nada más lejos de la realidad.
La inmigración favorece el crecimiento económico,
entre otras cosas porque la mayoría de los
inmigrantes son personas adultas en edad de
trabajar.
Fijaos.
(Se calcula que desde el año 2000 los inmigrantes
han sido responsables. ojo, de entre el 40
y 80 por ciento del crecimiento de la fuerza
laboral en los principales países receptores.
Vamos, que sin ellos, estos países serían
bastante menos ricos)
Pero… amigos, sí lo sé.
Como todo esto es bastante abstracto, si os
parece podemos fijarnos en lo que ha ocurrido,
precisamente, en uno de los países donde
últimamente más controversia ha generado
todo esto de la inmigración: el Reino Unido.
Pues bien, durante los últimos años, mientras
algunos grupos políticos alertaban sobre
la enorme amenaza que la inmigración [incluida,
ojo, la procedente de otros países de la
Unión Europea] suponía para los empleos
británicos, para su identidad, para su modo
de vida… lo cierto es que la economía ha
puesto sobre la mesa números muy, pero que
muy diferentes.
Nunca antes en la historia, tantas personas
habían tenido un empleo en Reino Unido como
en nuestros días, ni en términos absolutos…
ni tampoco en términos relativos.
Y, ojo, no importa si excluimos a los inmigrantes.
Nunca antes, nunca antes, la población de
origen británico había tenido tantas oportunidades
laborales como ahora.
(Y no solo eso, según los estudios de varias
universidades británicas… todos estos inmigrantes
pagan más impuestos de lo que obtienen del
Estado y por si todo esto no fuera suficiente,
Reino Unido está logrando atraer al mayor
número de inmigrantes universitarios de cualquier
país europeo.)
Es decir, en otras palabras: que el efecto
de esta inmigración está siendo muy pero
que muy positivo para los propios británicos…
y además está contribuyendo a convertir
a Reino Unido en toda una potencia tecnológica.
No está mal, ¿Verdad?
Pues… ¿Sabéis qué?
A pesar de los encendidos discursos de Trump….
lo cierto es que en el otro lado del Atlántico
las cosas no son nada pero que nada diferentes.
Atentos.
(EL SUEÑO NORTEAMERICANO)
Con algo más de 44 millones de personas - más
o menos la población de España - Estados
Unidos es en términos absolutos el país
con más inmigrantes de todo el mundo..
Sin embargo, esperad un momento… porque
en términos relativos… la cosa cambia.
Estás 44 millones de personas suponen algo
menos del 14% de toda la población.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en países como
Australia o Nueva Zelanda, por ejemplo, el
porcentaje es casi el doble.
Ahora bien, os hago una pregunta y no vale
mirar para otro lado:
¿Qué impacto pensáis que tienen los inmigrantes
en Estados Unidos?
Pues amigos… prestad atención:
(a pesar de representar algo menos del 14%
de la población, los inmigrantes son responsables
de casi el 25% de todos los negocios que se
abren en Estados Unidos; de más del 30% de
las empresas en que invierten los fondos de
capital riesgo y de prácticamente la mitad
de todas las start-ups de alta tecnología
de Silicon Valley.)
Y ahí no acaba todo… según un estudio
del Centro para el Emprendimiento, el 43%
de las 500 mayores empresas de Estados Unidos,
fueron fundadas bien por inmigrantes o bien
por hijos de inmigrantes.
216 empresas cuyos ingresos superan cada año
los 5 billones de dólares y dan empleo a
casi 13 millones de personas en todo el mundo.
Hablamos, ni más ni menos, del gran poder
económico de los Estados Unidos.
Amigos, desde Henry Ford a Elon Musk… muchas
de las grandes figuras, de los personajes
icónicos, de los Estados Unidos ni siquiera
nacieron en este país.
Pero, un momento… puede que alguno de vosotros
esté pensando, vale, Alberto… esto es cosa
solo de unos pocos inmigrantes, de los más
preparados, pero… ¿Qué pasa con el resto?
Pues… la verdad, los números no son muy
diferentes: sus tasas de emprendimiento y
empleo son también muy altas.
(Y, además, aportan otras muchas beneficios…
por ejemplo en un país que en este momento,
no lo olvidemos, se encuentra en pleno empleo,
los nuevos inmigrantes refuerzan la competitividad
del país y permiten poner en marcha muchos
negocios que de otra forma no se hubieran
creado.)
Es decir, resumiendo: los inmigrantes reducen
la edad media de la población, tienen más
hijos, investigan más, son más emprendedores,
logran más patentes, etcétera, etcétera.
Pues bien, a pesar de lo contundente que son
los datos… y de que nunca antes en la historia
tantos estadounidenses habían tenido un empleo,
a políticos como Donald Trump, todo esto
de la inmigración sigue sin gustarles nada.
Claro que… ¿sabéis qué?
No es la primera vez que en Estados Unidos
los líderes políticos tienen un discurso
contra la inmigración.
Atentos.
(LOS PRECEDENTES)
Amigos, no es ni mucho menos, la primera vez
que en los Estados Unidos, el país de los
inmigrantes, se desatan campañas políticas
contra la inmigración.
Fijaos. ya por mediados del siglo XIX, el
movimiento político “Know Nothing” se
opuso a los inmigrantes, particularmente a
los irlandeses…. y poco después le tocó
el turno a los chinos.
Sí, habéis escuchado bien… ¡A los chinos!
Durante la segunda mitad del s.XIX fueron
muchos los chinos que llegaron a Estados Unidos…
y eso desencadenó una reacción popular bastante,
pero que bastante hostil.
("Desde Seattle hasta Los Ángeles, desde
Wyoming hasta los pequeños pueblos de California,
los inmigrantes chinos fueron obligados a
dejar negocios, abandonar ciudades, fueron
golpeados, torturados, linchados y masacrados,
generalmente con la mínima esperanza de recibir
ayuda de la ley" Inmigración, obra de la
Biblioteca del Congreso de los Estados Unidos.)
Todo esto porque básicamente en aquel momento,
los norteamericanos consideraban a los chinos
competencia.
(El caso es que en 1882 el propio Congreso
aprobó la Ley de Exclusión de los Chinos,
que no solo suspendió la llegada de nuevos
inmigrantes chinos sino que, además, a los
que ya estaban en Estados Unidos les hizo
la vida bastante complicada.)
Y aquí no acaba todo.
En 1924, después de que alrededor de 30 millones
de personas atravesarán el Océano Atlántico
para llegar a los Estados Unidos,
Washington estableció una política de cuotas
que reducía fuertemente el número de inmigrantes
que podían llegar y además… vetaba de
facto a los inmigrantes procedentes del sur
de Europa - como España -, del Este de Europa,
de Asia y de África.
Vamos, que los pocos que podían entrar tenían
que ser básicamente anglosajones.
Y, más recientemente, en 1994, el gobernador
de California, Pete Wilson culpó a los inmigrantes
hispanos de la mala situación económica
por la que atravesaba el estado… y
¿Sabéis qué hizo?
Pues… lanzó una campaña política contra
la inmigración e impulsó la conocida como
proposición 187, una ley que impedía el
acceso a los servicios sociales, educativos
e incluso sanitarios para todos los inmigrantes
en situación irregular.
[Era tan agresiva que apenas un año más
tarde el Tribunal supremo la declaró inconstitucional.]
Con todos los datos en la mano, creo sinceramente
que tanto en la Casa Blanca como en el Capitolio
deberían estar pensando no en deportar a
gente o en endurecer el sistema de acceso,
sino en cómo aprobar de una vez por todas
una reforma migratoria que realmente facilite
la llegada ordenada de más personas…. más
trabajadores, más emprendedores y más investigadores
para la gran economía norteamericana.
[Por cierto, en un próximo vídeo que intentaremos
esté muy pronto disponible en nuestra página
de Patreon y más tarde aquí en el canal,
hablaremos uno a uno de los grandes mitos
que existen sobre la inmigración.]
Pero ahora, turno para ti, ¿Crees que tu
país debe reducir la entrada de inmigrantes?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Y como siempre, si te ha resultado interesante
el vídeo dale a like y suscribite a VisualPolitik
si aun no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.